[Music]
i'm in the [ __ ] trenches i'm in
fortune i'm in reddit i'm in discords
i'm
in twitter i'm like i'm a [ __ ]
listener i'm just so [ __ ]
jersey and loud and [ __ ] me that it
confuses the [ __ ] out of people
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
all right gary so maybe let's just start
with for those that don't know like the
three people watching who
don't uh just give us kind of a real
quick update on who you are
and how you build such a large audience
and what you do on a day-to-day basis
thanks pomp uh bryce thanks for having
me
immigrant from the soviet union kind of
that scrapper life
lemonade sands garage sports cards which
are now back
you know just kind of lived it in the
80s parents were frugal and poor and
then middle class and frugal and then
upper middle class and frugal
so i'd always fight for mine buy my own
nintendo
like had all my businesses dad had a
liquor store dragged me in at 14
fell in love with wine collecting
launched an e-commerce wine business in
1996
one of the first in the country became
kind of a pioneer in that space
spent 22 to 34 building a monster
business for my parents took their biz
from a 3.8 to a
60 million business finally got to the
place where resentment started kicking
in and being like [ __ ] i got to build
something for myself my brother was
graduating college
let's do something we started an agency
called vaynermedia that i'm still the
active ceo of
thousand people 200 million revenue
business invested along the way early in
facebook twitter tumblr
and and always built content and always
realized personal brand was a leverage
point because i was capable
of building actual business kind of
almost the reverse of this podcast right
bryce and his contemporaries
i see much more thoughtfulness from this
crew that i did let's say from the vine
crew six years ago which is like
it's not just about getting that bag
it's like [ __ ] let's make sure we build
something along the way
you know 80 price of that crew is just
actually not going to be capable of
being an entrepreneur which is okay
hopefully they'll find ceos they'll find
investors they'll find partners
they'll be thoughtful 20 are actually me
in reverse right i was an operator
nobody on earth knew who i was when i
was 30 [ __ ] you're four years old
and then i built awareness and brand and
now siphon it back into my business
capabilities
and in a lot of ways i'm hopeful that a
lot of the creators on tick tock right
now in other places
play the reverse game of me i didn't say
a word and have no leverage from a
personal brand but as an operator
they're the reverse they have lots of
words a ton of audience a ton of
leverage
and if they're thoughtful and become
operators or become
thoughtful with who they partner with
they can build institutional
generational wealth and so that's why i
said yes to the podcast because i'm hot
on this topic because i want these kids
to win
instead of living gary coleman life
right so you're known on social media
for actually giving advice kind of like
just how you
how you did right there why do you
always give away
your secrets for free as far as
influencers marketing and advertising
a combination price of the following
talent because i have enough talent to
have the next idea
and the next idea and the next idea i'm
not crippled by like this is my one
thing my one moment
two legacy like i genuinely like
that i i know both of you very very very
lightweight
and i'm very grateful that as we get to
know each other more for real through
serendipity
or more importantly as you've talked to
the people closest to you that know me
the best
they have the nicest things to say about
me versus people who've only seen me on
the internet
so reputation and legacy matter to me a
lot and if i could be kinder better
stronger historically correct it builds
reputation aka brand
right and then just kind of like that
selfish selfless game
of this like it feels nice bryce like
admiration comes in a lot of different
forms
there's a lot of people that like you
because you're attractive
to them they're just real talk and and
that's cool i didn't have that luckiness
that you had
other people love lebron because of how
he can play basketball for me i have a
very different community because
i'm built on admiration people as a
matter of fact a lot of people aren't
even sure if i'm for real at first or
full of [ __ ] but
people tend to be sticky with me and
about
me and i about them on the merit of the
advice i've given i mean there's a lot
of kids running around right now
that have made an incredible amount of
money on sports cards because they
bought
40 lucas for 35 because they were part
of my community
and sold them for 1500 and that's just a
very big thing that happened to their
lives
and they trusted me because i always did
the right thing by them including this
and so
for me it's just all i've been taught as
a kind of old-school
immigrant kid like reputation what do
people say behind your back
spit on your hand shake a hand do that
do the right things
i like being liked you know i want to be
a great entrepreneur and i think
that comes in a lot of shapes and sizes
some will just be jeff bezos and oprah
winfrey and just a masked
wealth others like me i'd like to last a
mass wealth i'd like you know it's tough
to listen to somebody who didn't do it
for themselves
but i love that there's a different
relationship i have
with the audience than most
entrepreneurs that are of my ilk you
like helping out
people that's that's what your brand is
it's just
it's you know your brand becomes your
actions to your point
there are people in high school and
junior high in my career long before
there was any persona
that have come out three years be like
well he was doing this for me
over a drink 10 years ago that's exactly
right it feels nice i have something to
give i feel almost guilty
and gratitude that i have something to
give so [ __ ] it i'm gonna give it so
what's one piece of advice you'd give to
young
entrepreneurs watching this or even
social media people that want to start
most people live in high school until
they die so what's holding back so many
of you right this minute
from starting up honey i actually mean
honey like
you grew up with your grandma as a kid
making honey in the backyard
you like honey you see this whole dtc
happening
but you're too [ __ ] cool on tick tock
and you think if you started a honey
brand
people gonna make fun of you literally
that's what [ __ ] me up
or anything right pomp heavy and crypto
but has his passion for surfing and
people might say to him that are smart
you're distracted
pomp you're distracted you've got this
moment but he just likes it
he just wants to start a surfboard
company my advice is
get the [ __ ] out of high school other
people's opinions on your life
just don't [ __ ] matter they don't
play out it never plays out
you never on your deathbed are thrilled
that you listen to everybody else
you become you resent it and so my
number one advice is like
if you want to do something do it if
you're so [ __ ] cool they'll probably
follow you
i got [ __ ] laughed at with the sports
card thing now the [ __ ] coolest
people in culture are [ __ ] flexing
sports cards on social media
literally 36 months ago the coolest
people i knew the smartest people i knew
the richest people i knew were on some
[ __ ] behind my back of like
he's going crazy like what the [ __ ]
the matter with this dude why is he
doing this is
stupid this is dorky
all of those people are texting me every
day where do i get a
jordan psa 10 should i buy the charizard
what should i do about magic bird it
just sold for 700 000 when you told me
to buy it was 40
000. like is this over is it too late
like and i'm talking like
top 10 athletes top 10 hedge fund
managers top 10 tick tockers like
if you believe in it and you're [ __ ]
about it and it makes you happy
it will always work out gary one of the
things that's really interesting i think
is
most people know you as an operator you
then had a epic run a lot of people
don't probably realize how great of an
angel investor you were
in kind of early 2010's the number of
the hits you had it seems like you've
kind of swung back to operating and then
now
into baseball cards is it just the
natural
like what you're interested in is how
you balance out between operating and
investing or is there some
kind of method to the actual madness of
how you balance those two things
first of all it's a really thoughtful
question i'm flattered for you paying
attention to that level it's
really it's truly i mean it thank you
first i wanted to give back to my
parents bro
when i tell you being a soviet jew
you're the math around me ending up in
america and i'm such a [ __ ]
entrepreneur can you imagine me growing
up in communism that would have been
like
who the [ __ ] i would have drank so much
vodka at 11 years old i would have been
sad
so first it was like i gotta operate
this thing for my parents because i'm a
[ __ ] raw talent
like at 22 i knew who i was right i'm
going to the hall of fame like i
believed it i just i don't know what
else to tell you do i [ __ ] with kobe and
lebron like i get it being a child
and knowing and i wanted to put that
energy first for my parents because i
loved them the most i
felt like i needed to i had to it was
the right [ __ ] thing to do
my mom was the best [ __ ] mother my
dad worked every [ __ ] minute like
you know so and then i was like then i
like you know getting paid 60 70 80
000 a year when you're building a 20 30
40 million you're getting [ __ ] right
you don't own the business
and [ __ ] if i was doing it for you pump
you'd be paying me a half a million
a year so you're double [ __ ] when
you're the kid building a business for
your family business all the kids out
there listening right now
i know you're getting [ __ ] i know that
you're not getting paid enough
and i know you're the [ __ ] reason the
business is exploding and you don't own
it
and your parents say they'll leave it to
you but you're gonna pay [ __ ]
inheritance tax
and it feels [ __ ] up trust me it's
okay you got time
in your 30s 40s 50s to get yours if
you're so [ __ ] good
so pop i had to do that and then i had
like 150 saved 250 saved
because i live like [ __ ] like i'm the
reverse of the sway house like all these
kids i'm envious
i'm happy for them truly i am because i
lived like [ __ ] i worked 15 hours a day
i didn't have anything like i was giving
up my 20s for my parents so then i was
like [ __ ]
you get this little resentment thing
going you don't really represent your
parents you're like just like man
you wanted to do this but [ __ ] like you
know it sounds good at 22 but now i'm 31
i don't i've done these incredible
accomplishments and i have eight [ __ ]
dollars it kind of you know [ __ ] with
you
i see social at that point i was so
right about youtube email google adwords
i started having confidence that i was
more than a retailer because that's how
i thought of myself
i'm like [ __ ] i know what people are
gonna do you know you gave me a very
flattering
tweet the other day about you know 2014
bitcoin and sports cards three years
before
like i'm early at [ __ ] now sometimes i
don't bet enough sometimes you know
there's a million different things that
have happened in my career but i
until the day i die i know i'm going to
be good at this and i
i expect my wealth creation to get very
aggressive in my 50s and 60s
where i'm less passive about my age and
patience where i'm going to be probably
a little
more aggressive however i knew that i
needed to
catch up to my skill set and i went high
risk on facebook twitter and tumblr
because i was as confident as i am today
about michael jordan's rookie card right
on the record so it's documented it's
probably going to close this week at a
300 000 card
there's 0.0 chance that it's not a
million dollar card
including global financial meltdown so
good it'll go back down to 170
but within a five to seven year window
on the rebound that is going to be a
million dollar card because there's
enough demand
now to justify against the 317 units
you know i love when the bitcoin
community talks about 21 million or is
that the number
right i agree with that i'm like is that
yep they [ __ ] got it
this is not printing in perpetuity
supply and demand
i understood what was happening with
social i bet the farm
then i realized oh [ __ ] i might be the
best at this like
i need to see if i am am i the best at
just genuinely understanding
not only who bryce is earlier than most
people not only who the baby is
earlier than anybody not earlier not
only clubhouse earlier than anybody
not only like like i now do this in so
many arenas culture
business human let me build a death star
i'm the emperor this is real talk now
this is literally how it went through my
mind
i'm the emperor right i'd like to be a
little bit more yoda because the emperor
loses in the end but
i'm the emperor let me build a death
star which is vayner x
that is so big and so scalable that i
can do
sports cards and a direct to consumer
wine brand
and by 50 of puma and build
non-fungible tokens which i believe in
heavily right now and
all these things at the highest level
because if it's just me
i'm going to be able to do one thing i
know me i'm self-aware
i need chaos and my hands in 30 pots to
be happy
six will fail but [ __ ] 24 gonna
succeed
and i'm gonna be happy and so that's
what i've been building so i ate [ __ ]
this last decade
and built a [ __ ] death star and now
you're just starting to see me
kind of pop my hep out up and point it
right
do i want to point it to to get
awareness for crohn's disease because aj
wants that
do i want to point it to my homies and i
want to go into politics and make sure
they win the governorship
do i want to point it against my vayner
sports athletes my vayner talent
talent i think in the last two or three
years i felt the undercurrent of
some people starting to say wait a
minute gary might be a little smarter
than we thought
whereas like six years ago it's like
he's just a personality like he is what
he is
and i'm flattered by that i'm also
concerned
in a weird funny way because i've loved
being underrated a little bit even for
my overrated
gary v part i knew i was underrated as
gary vaynerchuk
and i knew that was actually my leverage
to building out what i'm building out
and i
finally think that people are starting
to figure it out
and i think my next two decades are
going to be super interesting how long
have you been into the cards
from 1986 to 1993 it was my entire life
i did cards heavy it's how i made my
money like my friends made fun of me to
not going to like the cool party
like my sophomore year of high school to
go to like a mall and set up a table
like it was a real passion mine i popped
back in for
40 seconds in 2003 because i thought
lebron was gonna be michael jordan
so i bought a ton of lebron packs and
got a bunch of lebrons
and then three years ago three and a
half years ago i just do what i do
how i knew who you were before you even
popped how i knew the baby and mega
stallion and ghana
i don't know if you remember but you
damned me and you like you text you said
keep pushing bro
i know it's super well because i love
encouraging kids because i i never know
if the person knows who i am or don't
when i do that for kids
but i know if they google it that might
just be a spark because i know the come
up
for athletes rappers influencers and i
know
i might just catch you on the one day
where like you get a negative comment or
have something go down
where you're just like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and i'm always hopeful that when i do
that for somebody
that it just gives them a charge of like
no no let me refocus like there's
something here
so i try to give karma like that like i
think most people that are smart like me
see somebody like you and they want to
manage you they want to get money out of
you
they want to sign you for a five-year
iron-clad deal i try to
go the reverse back to what i said
earlier about reputation i'm just trying
to [ __ ] bring
value i remember it like yesterday you
want to hear something better bryce that
you'll even give me more credit of
knowing that was probably after nine
months of knowing who you are right like
because i also want to make sure i get a
little read for the per like
so i basically know that i have this
thing i think it's starting to become
more
obvious it's gonna be really weird to
see what it plays out as i'm an old man
because am i going to be at a place
where at 67 where i'm like
the colorado rockies is a good real
estate thing and is it like
i have to be careful because i'm a
little worried that as my reputation
builds
that i'll be in this weird new place
where am i going to trick myself
into something because i know the
economic impact the second i say a word
have like
i really am thoughtful about this [ __ ]
but nonetheless long-winded way to say
it was thoughtful pump i knew that i had
something so i said let me operate
so that i can layer a spack i can layer
a fund
like and and and i needed to build
family pop right i have
25 to 40 people around me who've now
been with me for seven years close
who are like my internal family who can
be the heads of
when you think through kind of why
you're able to see some of this stuff
some of it is absolutely just a skill
it's all the intangible things that just
make you you what are the things that
you look for though to confirm except
because i think that what you're really
highlighting is like hey
sometimes i have an intuition but i
could trick myself i could also get a
false positive by simply just saying
gary believes you know x is going to be
big and then it kind of becomes big in
the short term so how do you actually
gut check yourself or make sure that
you're you're right on it i don't want
anybody to make a split video that
i make about myself like look what i
said when i was fat and had let's say
like
i don't need that video i don't need
that video and so it scares the [ __ ] out
of me the second there's a video that
bryce can do
that says hey guys and which would be
right don't just [ __ ] blindly listen
to garyvee
watch this and i'm like you know care
bears are coming back
and he's like where'd i [ __ ] here
like i'm so petrified of being wrong
pomp
because i'm so smart about brand and
reputation i believe
and i'm honorable like honor matters
right like i'm pumped about like
how i do my [ __ ] like people make
speculations about me in cards
like he pumps and dumps he says i
haven't sold a [ __ ] card
that's just the truth show me the
receipt i'll like good
good you know like it's really easy for
me to like i need to put my head on my
pillow i'm too far along in my
reputation at this point i'm just in the
precipitous of getting my respect
when lebron said i want my respect to
when he won the title this year
i'll be very frank it it rolled through
my body
i know where i'm at but i also know that
i'm wildly underrated
in my own feelings about me and i don't
want to do anything to [ __ ] that up i've
got to keep executing for the next 30
years exactly how i've been
and i'll put myself right where i want
to be on like i [ __ ] put my
heart on the field because i think of
entrepreneurship like sports
so it's really easy for me it's why i
don't have a lot of those losses pumped
right
so that's how i think about it i get a
lot of flack
for interrupting when i'm on podcast
when i do podcasts when i do my own
as you know because you're in a bitcoin
space i did pete's and i get i'm getting
drilled by the btc community on that
what's ironic about that i always laugh
is if people realized
97 of my life is listening it's just
when i pop up and do a podcast like this
i'm so pent up to want to talk because
i've been thinking and listening for so
long
i think it's because i listen more than
[ __ ] anybody bro i'm in the [ __ ]
trenches
i'm in fortune i'm in reddit i'm in
discords i'm in twitter i'm
like i'm a [ __ ] listener i'm just so
[ __ ] jersey and loud and [ __ ] me
that it confuses the [ __ ] out of people
but i think about listening everybody
everyone's looking at data that has
already been manipulated i'm looking at
raw data
and then using my natural talent to make
my intuition
and speculations which have been tried
and true for a long time now
i have a question for someone like you
what is the definition of success
my entire life is based on how many
people should go up to my funeral and
what is said when i'm dead
the definition of success for me is the
legacy it's funny i was with a father
today when i dropped off my kids at
school
and he's a big hockey fan a winnipeg
jets fan so we have that jets thing we
always kind of laugh
we were talking about hockey and i said
to him you know in 1992
3 and 4 i watched 80 to 90 of the entire
rangers games
the only time i did it was when i was
going back and forth because the knicks
were on two
and then they won the cup in 94 and i
literally stopped watching them and then
i said to him and i stopped watching the
yankees after 96
when they won i have a very close friend
who's extremely close friends with derek
jeter and we've had some jams through
the years
and i always tell him how sad i am that
i didn't really get to appreciate his
career because i kind of checked the
[ __ ] out in 96 and i didn't really
run with it but i'm the biggest jets fan
in knicks fan i
go crazy so i realized oh my god i'm a
thrill of the hunt guy right i'm in it
for the journey not the [ __ ] trophy
it's why my biggest business
accomplishments right rezzy which i
co-founded co-created helped operate got
like really was in there it's a monster
win nobody associates me with that
nine-figure exit
k-swiss is reversed people see the
garyvee part but i was in their
operation empathy whines i just sold it
recently
huge exit for direct to consumer brand
in 18 months honestly
nobody's thinking about that so a lot of
people are like garyvee's just full of
[ __ ] he's a talker
because i don't pump my own business
accomplishments
mainly because i don't give a [ __ ] bryce
would anybody talk slowly whether
like i judge people on how they judge me
so when i see pom put out that text i'm
like oh
this fucker's listening when him and his
brother are saying those nice things
about me and aj
they're paying further attention than
people in the ecosystem
how do i know that hey that was very
nice of them and not needed for them to
say that b
pomp's [ __ ] executing it in his space
so for me
i want the smartest people to think um
good and nice
i want the people that actually know me
in real life and can speak to something
in detail
to think i'm the best i don't need the
[ __ ] crowd
the home team boos the basketball team
when the other team goes on a 17-0 run
you know when a team starts a basketball
game and they're at home when we're back
in the crowd when i go back to the
garden
and the first [ __ ] game i go to the
bucks go on a 12-0 run to start the game
in the next call timeout
that place is booing and i think about
that every day bryce
that people cheering or booing me that
have no idea who i am
have no idea anything besides what i put
out there
i put that out there it's my fault that
i get excited
when i'm in conversations i interrupt
people they're right the person that
says i'm a dick face is right because
they're experienced in that way
like that's their perception but i have
to know what's underneath that and we
all do and i think that's what helps
people navigate
having too much notoriety i can't
imagine bryce the [ __ ] that's gone
through your head
in the last 24 months of your life
that's a lot of [ __ ] attention and
opinion
but if you're grounded in knowing that
you're a good person and that you have
good intent
and that you're human and you'll make
flaws and when you do they're gonna [ __ ]
all over you
as long as they're not real [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] they're like you know like
it's one thing to misstep like a human
it's another thing to do a crime or like
suppress somebody like bad [ __ ] and i
know i'm that person i got lucky i got
the right dna i got the right parenting
my [ __ ] is never gonna be [ __ ]
fraud or [ __ ] like [ __ ] that should
put me in jail or
it's gonna be like maybe i'm too loose
with a statement and people lost the
context i'm like oh [ __ ] start like what
i really meant there you know
so i'm cool and so for me
it's just living that life and that's
what works for me
and because i'm good inside i can then
send you that dm without wanting
anything in return
my life is based on legacy how much love
am i going to get
and what's really crazy about it bryce
because i think about this [ __ ] all the
time which is like this is so [ __ ] up
the thing i'm living my entire life for
is something i'll never see
it's so [ __ ] up like i i'm like i
always ask myself like
like i'm like is this good is this like
the most noble is this super [ __ ] up
am i a [ __ ] up dude like like it's
crazy to me the thing that drives me
is like almost in a weird way the thing
i don't give a [ __ ] about right because
if i don't give a [ __ ] about opinions
like who gives a [ __ ] if they give you a
statue or not
i just genuinely like being liked by the
people who actually know me
i like people so [ __ ] it's funny my
friends always make fun of me for not
liking animals
and it's not that i don't like dogs it's
just that i like people so much more
like so much more and i think that
is something i think a lot about that
people love their animals because
there's no feedback loop
right it's unconditional love or if it's
not you don't even know it
and people don't like people because
there is a feedback loop but for me
i'm too empathetic to the other person
the other line when somebody's [ __ ]
on me on social
i'm like man this dude is so unhappy
that he had to come to my [ __ ] page
watch my video and leave some dog [ __ ]
on me
i'm not mad for me or sad for me or mad
at him
i feel bad for him i love him like i
wish
he was in a better like i don't have
time to do anything other than what i
did for you bryce
right i don't have time to do anything
other than what i just did the pomp
which is say emphatically thank you that
was very nice of you it made me feel
nice
thank you for doing that i'm paying
attention to only positivity
optimism and practicality that's my poop
my poop
is positivity optimism and practicality
not the [ __ ] [ __ ] that people drop on
other people because they're actually
hurting inside
nobody who's ever [ __ ] on people
ever phases me
because they're [ __ ] emotionally weak
you got time to [ __ ] on someone you're
in a bad place
gary one of the concepts that i've been
thinking a lot about lately is this idea
of like a time billionaire so everyone
always talks about billionaires as
having a billion dollars but a time
billionaire is essentially
a billion seconds it's about 31 years
right so a million seconds
is like uh 11 days a billion seconds is
31 years and so
i heard this on tim ferriss had a guy
come on and he was talking about this
and so the whole idea is like bryce is
basically a two-time
time billionaire right he's got 62 years
of his life at least
you and i don't have that maybe we got
one so how do you think
about investors i love you i love you i
[ __ ] love you i say it differently i
think every kid
that [ __ ] with me is tired of me saying
patience they all want to [ __ ] punch
me in the face
they're like [ __ ] you dude like the
comedians that spooked me on tiktok
are so funny they're like like person
comes up gary i'm 91. you got a [ __ ]
time like you know like
i'm such a buyer of this [ __ ] thesis
pump i haven't heard that
time billionaire but i [ __ ] i'm about
that life yeah it's
when the dm like yo keep pushing leads
to me and bryce having dinner in la if
it wasn't kovid which would
it would have happened that whole dinner
would have been like kid listen to me
i would rip my [ __ ] arms legs and
give you all my money to be your age
it's that [ __ ] real to me time is
optimism
like i don't even think a kid should
even begin to get serious
other than tasting [ __ ] and trying [ __ ]
until they're 30. like don't even think
about it
take 18 to 30 or 22 to 30 depending on
parent college life and [ __ ] taste
try
explore like having your [ __ ] together
[ __ ] that
you're like that's rules of when people
die to 38 years old
the rules of dying at 100 which is
what's gonna happen to [ __ ] bryce
need to be about be strategic and learn
about yourself
at [ __ ] 18 22 to 30. how do i think
about it it's the greatest [ __ ] gift
assuming that this is very young given
bryce's audience who's listening
you [ __ ] are winning you guys [ __ ]
have it
[ __ ] what i have or you can't wait to
have a yacht or you want to make money
so you can hook up with a pretty girl or
boy or
like [ __ ] all that you have time so
when you think through it if you could
go back and be bryce at 21 you've got a
massive audience everyone's paying
attention
the good and the bad that comes with
that what are the moves that you're at
least thinking through and considering
if you're sitting in his seat right now
knowing that you want to be an
entrepreneur and an investor not just a
social media star
if you want to be an entrepreneur
investor i think you go work for
somebody humbly for a year that is your
dream person and bryce could shoot for
the [ __ ] moon go after bezos maybe
right this minute
somebody in his life is like jeff you
need to be way more contemporary and the
thought of
bryce being an intern for
contemporariness so he can shadow
jeff but jeff can get the 4-1-1 on the
streets
from bryce i'll tell you bob kraft i
mean i [ __ ] hate the pats everyone
knows that
but bob craft does that that's why he
[ __ ] with meek mill with michael rubin
that's why he wears [ __ ] air force
ones it's probably subconsciously and i
don't want to make this assumption this
is inappropriate but he also dates young
like
to me if i'm bryce and all those [ __ ]
that i see like the 55 that are like him
i would [ __ ] whether it's bezos
whether it's diddy whether it's jay-z
whether it's somebody even more rigid
like you know obviously there's the
famous ones but maybe if he's super
aware that it's fashion
and his favorite ceo is a little bit
more under the radar
it's not virgil it's actually the ceo of
reebok because he just likes to work i'm
pretty
sure everyone's saying yes you can
shadow me and siphon through osmosis
a [ __ ] real mba not that horseshit
that you'll pay for
and i'll siphon from you knowing who the
[ __ ] the people are that are actually
matter in the world right now for
everybody under 25 to me that's the
great
trade of society right now listen i'm at
the top of my craft
i'd have if that's those email means
like yo intern for me for a year
like i even i'm like i probably wouldn't
like i don't want a [ __ ] here but
[ __ ] i would sit on that for a week and
be like
you know so whoever that is for that kid
right now
don't do the famous one like oh okay
it's elon or it's [ __ ] like
take a step back and listen elon's both
so you got to take
that you know app ad if you can get it
but
maybe it's somebody a little more boring
but really [ __ ] doing it and then it
goes to who the [ __ ] are you like if you
know that
you're famous now but actually you want
to you want to actually rep
everybody one day well then it's michael
ovitz maybe it's ari
right at wme like like there's a trade
there for those kids there's a trade
pomp are you doing any sports card [ __ ]
i mean pokemon cards bryce i'm telling
right now and i think i still i think i
said this to josh richard
somebody's going to win the tick tock
sports card thing and it's going to
really matter
like it's [ __ ] there for the taken
like
be educated because if you're saying
dumb [ __ ] it's going to always back to
what i said earlier like talk about what
you know
but when i [ __ ] tell you this thing
is really happening not kind of
it's really happening do you like sports
price i'm not really into sports now
then go deep into pokemon yeah pokemon's
really interesting to me i don't know
why
i grew up with that stuff brother you
should get real real
real educated because the
fractionalization market is going to
take the super premium to the [ __ ]
mood
all right i'm super over already i'm
happy to do part two another time guys
thank you so much for coming on youtube
watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you